one question about the flynn effect
what is it are humans getting smarter
over the years over the decades over the
centuries
the flint effect is james flynn who
passed away about a year ago
published a
a set of analyses
going back a couple of decades
when he first noticed this that iq
scores
when you looked
over the years seem to be drifting up
now this was not unknown to the people
who
make the test
because they renorm the test
periodically and they have to renorm the
test periodically because what
10 items correct
meant relative to other people
50 years ago is not the same as what 10
items mean relative
today
people are getting more things correct
now the scores have been drifting up
about three points iq scores have been
drifting up about three points per
decade
this is not a personal effect this is a
cohort effect was not for an individual
but the world what how do you explain so
what's that and this has presented
intelligence researchers with a great
mystery
two questions
first is it effect
on the fifty percent of the variance
that's the g factor or on the other
fifty percent
and there's evidence that it is a g
factor effect
and second what on earth causes this and
doesn't this mean intelligence and g
factor cannot be genetic
because the scale of natural selection
is
much much longer
than a couple of decades ago
and so it's been used
to try to undermine the idea that there
can be a genetic influence on
intelligence
but certainly it can be
the flint effect can affect the
non-genetic aspects of intelligence
because genes account for maybe 50
of the variance
uh maybe higher it could be as high as
80 percent for adults but let's just say
50 percent for discussion
um
so the the flynn effect is it's still a
mystery
it's still in this shape it's still a
mystery although the evidence is coming
out i told you before i edit a journal
on intelligence and we're doing a
special issue in honor of james flynn so
i'm starting to see papers now on the
really the latest research on this
um i think most people who specialize in
this area of trying to understand the
flint effect
are coming to the
view based on data
that it has to do with advances in
nutrition and health care
um
and there's also evidence
that the effect is slowing down and
possibly reversing
oh boy so
how would nutrition how so that
nutrition would still be connected to
the
g factor so nutrition as it relates to
the g factor so the biology that leads
to the intelligence
yes that would be the claim like
uh the the the hypothesis
being tested by the research yes and
there's some evidence from from infants
um
that nutrition has has made a difference
and so it's not an unreasonable
connection
but does it negate the idea that there's
a genetic influence not logically at all
so but it is very interesting so that if
you
take an iq test today
but you normal but you take the score
and use the tables that were available
in 1940
you're going to wind up with a much
higher iq number
so are we really
smarter than a couple of generations ago
no but
we might be able to solve problems a
little better
and make use of our rg because of things
like sesame street
and other curricula in school more
people are going to to
to school
so there are a lot of factors here to
disentangle
you